[Music]
up next a live viewer call in program we
are joined by david mcmichael washington
director of the association of national
security alumni a group which is opposed
to the use of covert action in
intelligence gathering he will take your
calls to discuss the operations of the
cia and the intelligence community
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
david mcmichael the washington director
of the association of national security
alumni in today's political climate what
do you think the responsibilities of the
cia should be
well the responsibility of the cia
should be those
still laid out basically in the national
security act of 1947
and that is to collate analyze the
intelligence information
and provide
the final
evaluation of this to the decision
makers particularly president united
states as a former employee of the
agency yourself how do you think
the cia has changed the way it's doing
business today
well one thing is that the cia
has been gravely let us say weakened
vis-a-vis the the department of defense
over the last few years i think it's
also having to overcome considerable
embarrassment for what are perceived as
major intelligence failures and of
course still battling the iran contra
scandal
one of the issues that seems to come up
in a lot of articles that have been
written over the last couple of months
is a so-called turf battle between the
cia and the defense department explain
that
well it has to do uh uh
in in one level with the the vexed
affair of so-called covert operations
and this really gets to be a
constitutional matter
uh the president of the united states as
you know and especially this one mr bush
has been very intolerant of what he
regards as congressional intrusion into
his area of responsibility in the
conduct of foreign policy and in in
covert operations covert actions and
i think the temptation to rely upon the
constitutionally based commander in
chief authority to go directly through
the armed forces rather than through the
the legislatively corre created
intelligence community
is almost overwhelming at this time and
there's much chapter and verse on this
in various presidential messages
before we get our first call some
background information if you could give
us on the cia what kind of authority
does it have
well the cia's authority very
interestingly has been limited to one
piece of legislation going back to 1947
and an enormous amount i think by the
general accounting office's uh
the congressional research services
uh account of the last uh two years ago
basically has re relied on executive
orders some
some twelve hundred of them as a matter
of fact but as our viewers can see with
the graphic now on the screen no powers
to arrest and no powers of prosecution
that's that's correct this was a major
concern of the congress when the
proposal for a central intelligence
agency was created of course was a major
concern of the late j edgar hoover as
well
good afternoon from washington our guest
is david michael who is the washington
director of the association of national
security alumni we will be taking your
calls in just about a minute or so
you'll see the number on the bottom of
your screen for you folks living here in
the east coast or midwest the number is
202-628-2525
and for our viewers on the west coast
the number is 202-783-2727
as we continue our special programming
this afternoon in preparation for
tomorrow's confirmation hearings of
robert gates to head the cia have you
ever met bob gates oh yes i met mr gates
when oh when
when i was working in the agency in
1980s early 1980s and
i i will not claim a friendship or
familiarity with him let's just say i've
met him any very pleasant fellow any
impression at all that stands out
uh the only impression i ever took away
from my personal contact with mr gates
uh let me say that he was in fact a very
uh
uh
not exactly hale fellow well-met but but
certainly an open and frank and a
friendly person yes let me read you a
quote from this morning's new york times
it refers to richard kerr who is of
course the acting director of the agency
at the moment and he says that until mr
gates or another candidate is
permanently confirmed for the job he
says that uh the whole issue of the iran
contra affair troubles him because he
according to this article
told bob gates about the iran contra
affair in august 1986 more than a month
before mr gates has publicly said he
first heard about that bringing up the
whole issue of credibility
your response to that particular
incident well it means that mr gates who
had to field many of these same types of
of questions and uh the lack of
credibility uh during his uh hearings
the hearings in 1987 when he was first
nominated is going to have to face them
again and this time much more strongly
because people within the agency like
like richard carr coming forward with
their recollection of the chronology
what are you looking for this week
i'm looking for a
a very hard hitting
affair in which the contest will be
between some democrats on the committee
who wish to use the gates nomination to
reopen
the iran contra affair
and
with
republican members who wish to use it to
quiet the whole thing down
and this
part of this goes toward protection of
the president part of this goes toward
protection of the president
charges and rumors abound as to george
bush's involvement in those years and
it's and it's most important to the
administration to say these were handled
finally in these hearings and found not
worthy of consideration and put down
first caller from new york city go ahead
please
it seems to me that we owe a great debt
of gratitude to the cia
actions uh the post-world war ii period
helping to preserve our freedom
specifically uh recently the russian
foreign minister has acknowledged that
ronald reagan was right and that the
soviet union really was the evil empire
throughout that period
and my question is an expert on
intelligent matters do you think as we
have a little bit more openness now
within the soviet union
that some of the information as far as
the kgb's involvement in the attempted
assassination of the pope or in the
assassination of president kennedy will
be divulged or do you think that's
information it'll be buried deep forever
well uh caller i i can tell you that one
of the great
growth industries in europe over the
next year or two
is going to be the purveying of hot
stuff information allegedly from the
secret files of of the kgb but in regard
to the the overall question yes i'd
welcome a lot more openness on all sides
in the handling of so-called secret
information what is the national
association of security alumni the
association of national security alumni
are a group of former
cia
officers fbi
agents we have one or two members from
the from the drug enforcement
administration whose general position is
in calling for more openness
in the handling of so-called classified
information and secrecy and particularly
to oppose the use of covert actions to
implement foreign policy we have another
caller on the line where are you calling
from
miami florida go ahead and gentlemen
good evening uh if i understand
correctly what you seem to be advocating
is uh doing away with uh covert cia
operations
uh that may work uh good in
areas of democracy or glasnost but what
would we do for instance in china
to get information or
iraq
in the future places like that
but i i do want to make one comment i
don't believe any president
should have
a cia force to operate in the name of
the american people i believe it should
be brought under accountability of if
not the entire congress because i
realize there are leaks but the the the
committee for intelligence
okay the quick answer to your question
is that what you describe it is the the
the clandestine or secret gathering of
information uh is not covert action
covert action by uh by definition are uh
and has just been uh defined in law for
the first time these are activities of
the united states government influence
political economic or military
conditions abroad where it is intended
the role of the united states government
will not be apparent or acknowledged
publicly these are interventions in in
politics in economic affairs and
sometimes include paramilitary or
military actions
dave mcmichael was born in albany new
york in 1928 served in the u.s marine
corps from 1946 until 1959. good evening
where are you calling from los angeles
go ahead please uh yes i'd like mr
mcmichael please to
comment on the uh danny cassilaro
alleged suicide and also on some of the
investigative work that cassolaro was
doing which i know he knows about
connections between bcci
insla
october surprise and iran contra and
there is a lot of evidence
or at least you know
connections that can be made between all
those four events in particular and if
you please comment i'd appreciate it
before commenting maybe you should
clarify who danny cassidy that's very
quickly and this this covers a great
deal universe danny castellero is a or
was let's say
a uh an author and a researcher who was
pursuing a number of uh
sources into the clandestine world and
was found dead in a hotel room in west
virginia something over over three weeks
ago uh there's a great deal of
controversy his family
does not believe that mr castellero in
fact killed himself
and
there is speculation that
he was getting
as they say too close to important
information as a matter of fact
mr caslero called me the day he left for
his his final trip to west virginia and
said he almost had it wrapped up he knew
what he was going to write about so
yes he was
and
had taken a great deal of notes on such
things as bcci the insula case and
others but the specifics beyond that i
can't go because i don't know do you
have any gut feeling on the whole case
oh boy i've learned to distrust gut
feelings on this sort of thing i i can
only say that
mr casolero's
family
and most people who dealt with them do
not believe it and that he committed
suicide and i will also say that if in
fact my strong belief
is that
if it were not death by his own hand
this had something to do with the the
inn's law case and we really don't have
time i think to get into the details of
that
we have about 35 more minutes with david
michael our next caller is from new york
city go ahead please hello mr mcmichael
uh i want to thank you for
being so straightforward
and
i wanted to ask you also about the
insular case
however you
you just said that
you can't get into that now
what i would also like to know is what
your opinion or feeling is with regard
to robert gates's knowledge
of the iran contra
affair
and any of the other uh previously
noted allegations
thank you
well this of course is going to be the
focus of
mr gates
interrogation now he was weighed in the
balance once in 1987 and found wanting
in terms of credibility and it's hard
for me to believe that the passage of
three and a half years is going to make
him that much more credible especially
against the background of the
indictments of the indictment of claire
george and the guilty plea of alan fires
frankly what mr gates faces is is the
situation is this uh it's very clear
from
judge walsh's
investigation that there was a
widespread pattern
of lying by cia officers to the
congressional investigating committees
and to the independent council's
investigators themselves during the very
period when mr gates was acting director
of the cia following william casey's
death and if he were aware of that
of course mr gates himself should be
indicted if he were aware of that and
did not reveal it or take any steps to
do anything about it he should also be
indicted and if
this pattern was so widespread as it
appears to be mr walsh has about 50
current and former agents whom he
could charge with perjury why then one
would have to question his
administrative ability and wonder if he
is capable of running the cia what will
you be doing this week i i'll be uh
following this as part of the pacifica
radio
team at the hearings it's just subject
of great interest to me
and of course c-span will have live
gavel to gavel coverage beginning
tomorrow at 9 30 a.m our coverage though
will begin at 7am with more of your
calls on the confirmation hearings of
robert gates our next caller from
seattle washington good afternoon thank
you this is in the congressional record
of june 22 of 1987. so this has been
substantiated fully the ci uncovered in
the investigation of communist terrorist
activities in central america they
uncovered letters from pat schroeder
irvin dymaley and john conyers that were
requesting information and monies to
support this government that was not
recognized by our government why is
there an investigation on this these are
facts these are not supervision
well i don't know what uh government
you're referring to that was not
recognized by the united states uh in in
the year that you describe if you mean
nicaragua of course nicaraguan
government the san anista government if
you will was a recognized government we
we exchanged ambassadors the embassies
were open in both
in both countries
so
what what the problem is i don't really
know
elton maryland go ahead please
yes that's kind of interested in whether
or not there's much rivalry between the
the cia and the fbi in their overseas
operations
well technically speaking uh the the
fbi's overseas operations are very
limited we have
a uh
at many embassies there will be a uh
what we call a legal uh
liaison officer
uh who'll usually be an fbi uh
agent whose business is to uh follow up
uh in foreign countries matters of
interest uh domestically to the to the
go ahead please
yes that's kind of uh interested in
whether or not there's much rivalry
between the the cia and the fbi in their
overseas operations
well technically speaking uh the the
fbi's overseas operations are very
limited we have uh a uh uh at many
embassies there will be a uh what we
call a legal uh liaison officer
who'll usually be an fbi uh
agent whose business is to
follow up in foreign countries matters
of interest domestically to the to the
fbi
historically of course uh mr hoover at
the time of the
uh creation of the cia was uh was
terribly uh opposed to giving any form
of
of police or surveillance or any
domestic powers at all
uh to to the new cia and in fact was
less than completely cooperative with it
for a very long time but uh
and i can tell you right now with a
matter that mr colby referred to during
his talk here about the the the
paralysis which he talked about in
getting uh soviet agents for some years
this was uh while he did not say so this
was due to the uh the activities of uh
the i would say almost certifiably
insane james angleton while he was head
of counterintelligence for the cia
and of course this totally disrupted his
activities totally disrupted
not only cia activities but with a very
great uh
disruption of fbi activity and the fbi
simply broke off relations for some time
because of that some additional
background information on our guest
david mcmichael as i said earlier was
born in albany new york graduate of
hampton sydney college phi beta kappa
and also earned your master's and phd at
the university of oregon he's also the
editor of unclassified which is your
newsletter yes how many people receive
that oh we have a paid subscription list
now almost 700 people and we certainly
hope to expand that hollywood florida go
ahead please yes good afternoon
gentlemen
uh three-part question i have for you
today uh first question uh your
familiarity and comments with the mk
alter program
and also on that question uh what to
what extent does the cia still have uh
links or are they investigating uh mind
control type activities as they were
during that mk ultra program uh the
second question why don't you stay we'll
try to take each one at a time if we can
we'll go with the first one
okay mk ultra to which the caller refers
with the program started by uh then uh
deputy director for operations richard
helms in 1953
to experiment with the use of
hallucinogens particularly lsd
and other
let's say bizarre
psychiatric methods
to get at uh what was then believed to
be the communist secrets of brainwashing
which of course did not exist there's an
excellent book on this by the way called
the search for the manchurian candidate
by by john marks uh more important
though and i think this gets directly at
the cia aspect of this
is
these experiments were carried on
through a
cia front called the institute for the
study of human ecology which had been
established at cornell university
medical school and then funded these
activities which were unwitting
experiments on at least nine canadian
citizens over a period of years uh at
the allen memorial institute in in
canada which resulted in severe mental
and physical damage i mean these things
were just
very bad
a lawsuit was filed in 1973 orlakow
versus the united states which was
finally settled out of court after 15
years
of litigation
and this is a scandal i really want to
say this this is a genuine scandal
involving the cia because throughout the
course of this trial the cia and the
united states government generally
stonewalled on this the evidence was
very plain
and none of those involved including the
chief psychologist of the of the cia in
various deposition expressed the least
regret for this the case finally had to
be settled out of court a very limited
uh settlements for the victims because
they were get they were old and about to
die many of them one had as a matter of
fact and of course the litigation is
always going to be a very severe stain
on the on the reputation of the cia and
the united states government entirely i
really mean that carla you had a
follow-up yes i have second question
given again such unscrupulous activity
in the past what are your comments
regarding the connection between george
bush who was cia director in 1976 and
paid informants such as president mill
noriega of panama and did the cia in
fact help to bring drugs or allow drugs
to flow into this country
the the my stock answer to that
uh is to say that in in my
experience which is not uh
extensive in this but i have some is
that so-called covert operations on any
scale and drug trafficking go together
like dogs and fleas i can
recommend to you a recent book by
peter dale scott and jonathan marshall
called cocaine politics
dealing with this with former dea as
drug enforcement assistant
drug enforcement agency
officer mike levine
who is very critical of cia involvement
with the drugs overseas called the most
important book on the subject that
anyone can possibly read this is an
article in the washington times by
syndicated columnist cord meyer the
headline revising clandestine priorities
what are they revising
well in this case the uh
interestingly the the priorities now are
supposed to go on to matter such as
drugs onto matters such as terrorism and
a particular favorite of the recently
retired judge webster economic
intelligence
several people have referred to this as
uh
critics let me say of the cia as
desperately casting about permission is
simply to stay in business
do i get more calls we have about a half
hour less with david mcmichael our next
caller where are you calling from
portland oregon yes go ahead please uh
my question is very straightforward uh
what explanation can you mr mccollum
offer
for why americans are no good at what is
called human or human intelligence
we can't put people on the ground
we can't generate people who can
just go out
you know to a restaurant
and talk to a source
and come back with information that uh
would tell us whether or not that baby
milk factory in baghdad really was a
baby milk factory or not we got to hear
it from peter arnett americans or the
kinds of americans that
go into your business
just seem to be no good
if they learn a language they want to
become an aficionado of the place
well i this is uh
voicing a lot of criticism one does hear
about
cia
activities in the plain old-fashioned
business of espionage and there have
been very very significant intelligence
failures one of them of course being in
in the case of iraq and why didn't we
have more agents on the ground and or
and more officers on the ground what
were the priorities given there these
are these are questions to which i
frankly don't don't know the answer but
i can also
tell you that
this matter is being addressed but mr
colby also referred to this we have an
enormous take now
from from technology the satellites the
listening devices and so forth and uh
there is some question as to
what what in fact is the value as
compared to the risk
of attempting to place uh uh
large numbers of uh of case officers out
there attracting ever larger numbers of
agents to to work for you the the whole
business is trying to
uh
gather uh
as against capabilities what our
people's intentions is is a very
difficult one most recently as you
mentioned in the case of iraq uh it was
president bush himself who dismissed the
uh the probability analysis presented by
the mideast experts and both defense
intelligence and and the cia that iraq
probably would attack on the grounds and
this is humid his recent conversations
with hosni mubarak of egypt and king
hussein of jordan welcome back to that
issue but our next caller from rochester
new hampshire go ahead oh yes well i'd
like to a direct question to mr
mcmichael um the press has had a lot
about how the cia's had
public accountability through having to
report to the senate and all that a lot
of what i haven't seen is how is the nsa
publicly accountable is it is it
publicly accountable
no as a matter of fact the the nsa
is not accountable except to the extent
that its budget
is uh
a portion of the intelligence
authorization which is
worked on every year
the nsa of course is is not an
organization which does anything or
should not be doing anything much beyond
collection otherwise priorities are
given to to the nsa as to
what things to be listening for in what
areas of the world and the take from
that enormous effort is uh is piled up
on the uh the unhappy analysts at
langley and in the defense department
this is what the newsletter looks like
it's called unclassified
you mentioned earlier about uh the iraqi
invasion into kuwait what do you think
we learned from that whole incident
well
this the
iraqi invasion into kuwait uh i think
the information is fairly clear that the
the iraqi forces had pulled up into a
a situation which they could attack the
question became would they attack
uh the
i think one of the most important
lessons learned if indeed it was learned
goes back to decisions made six years
earlier seven years earlier in fact
during the iran-iraq war when the united
states made its tilt toward iraq
in
meetings in baghdad by high us
intelligence officials as i am informed
and uh at that point we uh as a former
high-ranking national security council
officer howard tyker said in an
interview in the washington post some
months ago
said we were so busy giving intelligence
to iraq we didn't spend any time
gathering intelligence about iraq and
perhaps that is uh if there's a lesson
to be learned there it's that you are as
assiduous in these instances in
collecting intelligence information
uh on those you consider your your
friends at this time as you are
against those you consider your enemies
next caller from minnesota go ahead
please
yes it was mentioned earlier that mr
mcmichael believes that there should be
intelligence gathering without covered
operations how how is that possible
well i thought i'd explain that because
covert action covert operations have a
particular definition these are actions
undertaken
by the united states government to
influence political economic or social
results in another country in which the
action the participation the united
states
is to be concealed or if revealed
plausibly denied these are positive
actions these are the things like fixing
elections for example
uh or uh sabotaging uh uh the harvest
all things that have been done by the
way
the covert gathering
of information is not considered covert
action the reason there is a difference
is because in order
for the intelligence
community to carry out a covert action
there has to be a presidential finding
which determines under the new law that
such action is necessary for the
national security and to achieve a
definable united states foreign policy
objective and that finding has to be
presented to the congress
to the congressional oversight
committees the committees in in the
senate and the house
they cannot
prohibit these but
they must be informed about them so
there's a real difference here and i
hope that i hope that answers your
question
eugene oregon go ahead please
this is fairbanks alaska talking to me
sorry about that but go ahead fair
blanks glad you're on the line yes okido
mr mcmichael would you comment on
allegations made in a well-documented
book by mr stephen mumford the book is
american democracy and the vatican
population growth national security put
out by the humanist press and the
allegation is that the cia is dominated
by roman catholics
well uh
you know certainly there have been roman
catholic directors of the central
intelligence agency john mcconne for one
but
i don't think uh uh one could uh you
know by that there have been there are
other allegations at various times that
the cia was controlled by wasps white
anglo-saxon protestants or laterally by
mormons so you take you take your pick i
uh i will say this with regard to the
comment however
uh
in various parts of the world at various
times such as italy in the immediate
post-war uh sec world war ii era or in
latin america uh up until a very recent
period
it has been a tendency for the united
states government to regard conservative
elements
within the roman catholic church as as
allies in the united states policy and
therefore our intelligence agencies have
in one way or another attempted to uh
use sources within there or to work on
sometimes covert actions there but i
don't think i could endorse your
statement that the the cia is is
dominated and or controlled by roman
catholics how long did you work for the
agency i was
in the pension plan as they say for just
25 months
eugene oregon is still on the line
thanks for waiting go ahead please
this is eugene oregon yes go ahead
please
i wanted to comment and then a
question my comment is that mr mcmichael
shows a
rather definite anti-cia bias based on
his 25-month
exposure this always makes me
leery of a person like the camel who
gets outside the tent and then does his
business back into the tent
i believe there's some bias there it
always makes me want to see the fella's
uh
efficiency report and see what kind of
action he had
we'll we'll ask him about that in the
meantime you might want to turn the
volume down on your set so we can hear
your question but your response to his
first comment
well uh uh i have never attempted to
portray myself as a
a
a professional uh cia officer or a door
uh employee
i had as i say 25 months working as a gs
14 senior estimates officer with the
national intelligence council during the
period
that i mentioned from time to time both
before and after that i carried out
under contract some some activities
usually of a research nature or always
as a matter of fact the research nature
for the cia and various overseas
assignments usually under department of
defense contract in central america and
in southeast asia in the 1960s i think i
had
ample opportunity to view and some cases
coordinate with certain agency
activities but
as far as my my so-called efficiency
reports
can i say they're classified
you have a follow-up sir
yes uh
i just wanted to get on record that i
don't believe the alumni association is
typical of the ex-intelligence officer
attitudes second part the substantive
question
as to do he seems to be uncomfortable
with the relative positions of the cia
versus the defense
intelligence activities
i'm certainly not uncomfortable with it
i'm
what i've tried to present here is is
what i regard the very interesting
evolution
in which
the department of defense and its
various
intelligence agencies including the dia
and the uh the special operations
command
uh are assuming a more and more powerful
position within the intelligence
community and i think mr colby referred
to that in
his remarks as the
fact that you were going to run up
against a very tough and determined
secretary of defense richard cheney yeah
that's true
long island new york go ahead please yes
i'm i'm wondering if the gentleman
could comment as to whether or not
really the american people
are in position
whereby they would know
whether or not
there were sinister secret
conspiratorial powerful groups
dominating our government
and their past and present actions could
be hidden
well uh
you know you're getting you're getting
into one of the perennially uh popular
areas for for speculation and i think it
goes without saying that in
in any society in any community there is
a uh an establishment that is true uh
you know whether these uh these groups
which at various times seem to uh
exercise inordinate influence in
in in the government or represent in
fact sinister conspiracies or
merely uh
well-organized economic or social
interests
uh which are characteristic of what
politics is all about and some of them
in fact do try to operate behind the
scenes as well in the city of washington
there are very large numbers of
lobbyists who get very well paid to
contact people for these purposes uh is
is is certainly uh
an ongoing question but i'm i'm not
prepared with the any knowledge i have
to say that there is uh uh you know such
a conspiracy and that it is effective
and is controlling i i have a good deal
of faith in the
in the people of the united states and i
think that
the political system which we have
uh and the sources of information which
are available to people in which they
can apply through that political system
would militate against the uh
let's say the permanent establishment of
such a conspiracy in this country
madison wisconsin good afternoon hello
um i you commented earlier on the
relationship between covert activities
and and drugs like dogs and fleas
the the i'd like you to comment on some
information that had come out after the
iran contra hearings
in which
john hull in costa rica was indicted for
uh murder
uh
illegal drug trafficking and gun running
in costa rica and this is where
the
cia well he doesn't admit he's a cia
informant but
um
he's
supposedly
this is where the uh
guns and
or money and drug whatever were brought
in by the cia for money for the contras
i'd like you to comment on that yeah
well this mr john whole's story is an
interesting one and in fact he has
stated publicly that
he is a uh
a cia asset in his case he was uh
declared that he was receiving up to ten
thousand dollars a month to uh
repay him for the use of his uh his
ranch in northern costa rica for various
activities involving the
the supply of the contra forces and it
is also true as you say that the costa
rican government has under its system
effectively indicted him
uh charged him with international drug
trafficking and has asked for his
extradition from the uh
from the united states this request for
extradition was made
i think almost a year ago
at this point and uh
it seems to be preceding a very
snail-like manner
i think there are strong elements in the
costa rican government at least my
friends there tell me this who are not
really too serious or wanting him there
because it involves a lot of costa rican
politicians as well
and the united states government uh has
given every indication over the years of
wishing to
uh give maximum protection to uh to mr
hull this is a story that has yet to be
fully told but there is uh there is a
lot there and it
by way of being a a small scandal yeah
our preview of the robert gates
confirmation hearings will continue
until the top of the hour and dave
michael will be here for about 14 more
minutes to take more of your calls
walnut california go ahead please yes
this is susan amaya hi
my question is what is the relationship
or difference between the cia and the
national endowment for democracy
well when the national endowment for
democracy was legislated into existence
in 1983
congressional testimony and statements
on the floor at that time
was that this would allow the united
states now to do overtly
the sort of political intervention which
the cia had been doing covertly
and in fact the
[Music]
one can only say you know democracy is a
good thing a national endowment for
democracy is a good thing uh one
questions though uh whether
let us say the united states
would submit with good grace to a
foreign nation's uh
organizing an endowment to come into the
united states and expand large sums of
money in our electoral contest a matter
of fact is prohibited by law here
but
we we do use this in other countries the
nad has been used in panama in
uh in the philippines in nicaragua there
is a large plan for its operations now
in angola in the planned election is
there
but
i
i hesitate to say that relationships are
official or close
but
i uh i think in a case in which i know
reasonably well
uh the nicaraguan elections of
1990 that uh
the action
in terms of support for the candidates
the united states favor was very closely
coordinated with the covert activities
undertaken by the by the cia over a
number of years any connection though
between the nad and some of the people
who run that oh yeah as a matter of fact
oh yeah you can uh you can check into
the backgrounds of people who have been
uh
the ned works through uh contractors
it's composed the national endowment
board is composed of the the foreign
policy branches of both the republican
and the democratic parties
the
the farm
institute of the af of lcio and a
similar body of the united states
chamber of commerce
and the
the contracts which they award
uh to
you know through uh
the appropriations from congress
uh the people who've received these uh
not infrequently are have been
associated with in fact our former uh uh
united states intelligence employees
this is not to say that once they leave
that employee they're not free to use
their their foreign expertise to seek
contracts but uh you know this this sort
of thing does arouse the sort of
suspicion and comment which the you know
which the caller indicates and it
happens to be a matter of fact new york
city good afternoon
hello um
you know i sat through four days of the
thomas confirmation hearings and i'm
looking forward now to the confirmation
hearings for robert gates and
after watching the sunday morning shows
today with david boren saying that it is
very plausible that robert gates did not
know about what was going on with iran
contra
one thing that came to my mind and it's
making me somewhat angry is what
happened to common sense
is there no common sense in the american
public to
yes anything is perhaps plausible but
the idea that this man who is so
intricately involved with the cia did
not
have awareness or knowledge of what was
going on around him and going just back
to the analogy with
with clarence thomas the idea that these
senators spent four days discussing
the uh abortion and whether or not he
talked about it or even thought about it
common sense would tell you that he had
so why do we waste so much time will the
senators
just
um
basically protect the washington
establishment
and cover up so to speak for for someone
like gates and thomas or just use common
sense and say you know if i'm going to
be true to my own intelligence and not
insult myself as well as
the american people i will have i'm just
going to stop you we get your point
thank you for calling but your reaction
to what she had to say my reaction is
very similar to her
these matters were gone over with mr
gates in 1987 and uh frankly so many
doubts were raised
about his uh his credibility his his
competence
as a result of that that he withdrew his
nomination
now here it comes again as someone used
to say and
certainly more information has come out
since then
which indicates that if mr gates were
not more aware than he has admitted to
be
uh then one really has to question his
confidence and i think
the caller indicates that common sense
uh would say that that is so and many
critics of mr mr gates including those
from within the agency uh thomas poger
for one
uh have uh made very strong statements
saying that
to
give to mr gates after the uh the events
of iran contra and his uh his role
or at least his lack of of diligence and
vigilance while he was in a position to
exercise control been such that to put
him into the position of the director of
central intelligence would uh be very
damaging to the morale of the
intelligence community would give a very
bad signal as to how one succeeds in the
intelligence business portland oregon go
ahead please thank you with the
communist uh soviets
having admitted that there are 400 kgb
agents in this country
not knowing who they are don't you think
that we should have a better informed
cia and give them all the support we can
well caller the responsibility for kgb
agents in the united states belongs to
the fbi and its counterintelligence
activities and uh
in fact they do get a
a very significant budget by the
estimate of the federation of american
science on this uh their recent bulletin
the
the
fbi counterintelligence will get at
least 300 million dollars for their
activities this year
another five minutes or so with your
phone calls woodbridge virginia
yes i have a question relative to a book
that was published in 1989 by william
corson and cooperative with susan joseph
trento
in that book
they make allegations that the former
director of counterintelligence eglinton
as a result of an investigation by agent
claire petty was in fact named as a mole
for the soviet intelligence service
dating back to his relationships with
kim philby
in the 30s
well the relationships in fact were in
the uh in the in the 50s with kim philby
but
uh mr angleton's career was so bizarre
the man himself uh so
strange if i may use a euphemism here
that one of the great scandals i think
of the cia is that under three
successive directors alan dulles uh john
mcconne and richard helms
this man who by the estimate of uh the
chief psychologist of the cia itself was
a dangerous paranoid uh was permitted to
hold the position as long as he did we
we commented on that earlier there's an
excellent book on on mr angleton by tom
mangle published last year called the
cold warrior worth reading very quickly
how did we get uh information before the
cia what kind of operations did the u.s
have well the i think the point made by
mr colby is accurate that the united
states did not have a well-organized
intelligence system but the information
and that's a term i prefer to
intelligence by the way the information
that we got came principally from uh our
uh our uh you know our embassies abroad
and the military attaches they're at and
i can tell you very frankly that the
that the work even before that uh
particularly dealing with the with the
soviet union that was organized by uh by
george kennan and others was first class
stock
washington d.c good evening good evening
how are you doing tonight i um i was
just hearing a previous call from new
york who said that the senators should
almost take a reality pill and just sort
of assume that mr gates knew about this
problem with the iran contrary and then
go from there and i want to know is
there a single shred of evidence that mr
gates knew about iran contra that could
stand up in a u.s courtroom now i'm
looking here at the washington post
today and it says a script for mr gates
to be used with the house chairman but
it doesn't say he was given the script
and i've heard that people below him
knew about it and the people above him
knew it but it doesn't say mr gates knew
about it is there and i'm asking you on
you know your knowledge of this is there
a single shred of evidence that would
say definitively mr gates knew
well of course when you when you narrow
it down to definitively like that of
course it's impossible to give an
unambiguous answer but i can tell you
this that if you will go to the
transcript
of the uh of the hearings uh of uh held
on mr gates in 1987
uh when he was first nominated for this
post and you will go uh to the to this
grant transcript of his appearance
before the senate intelligence committee
to testify to what he knew about this
i think you will find a great deal of
evidence indicating the high probability
that he did now whether in a u.s
courtroom if this were in front of a
jury the weight of this evidence would
be sufficient to carry a verdict i'm not
prepared to say but don't talk about no
shreds of evidence there is plenty of
evidence it's much more than a shred and
i'm afraid a lot of the evidence has
been shredded
we have time for one more caller los
angeles california good evening hello
yes wonder if you could just go back
over who has access to the cia and how
that could be opened up more
well
i don't know what really i mean by who
has access to the cia is the
the cia's reporting
of course goes out to a great
number of uh officials particularly in
the in the executive branch or the
widespread distribution list for you
know for this sort of sort of reporting
the congress of course gets periodically
its
its reports in front of the uh
the the select committees on
intelligence and as far as other access
goes with some difficulty but it is
still possible
you can use the freedom of information
act and the average citizen can get
a certain amount of information but i
will tell you this
that one of the worst flaws of the
central intelligence agency has been an
acts excessive secrecy just last year
the very distinguished professor warren
cohn
resigned as did most of his colleagues
from the state department's review board
for the foreign relations series because
of the total refusal of the cia to
give up documents now 35 and more years
old in countries like
iran and guatemala where major
activities were carried out by the ci
and as professor cohen said this amounts
to a fraud on history this is this is a
problem
will robert gates get confirmed
uh i do not believe i'm going to i only
go out on the limb on this when i say i
do not believe mr gates will be
confirmed
david mcmichael the washington director
of the association of national security
alumni thank you for your time thanks
for having me steve
and the programming note we will
continue our look at the confirmation
process for robert gates coming up next
an interview with steve emerson who is a
correspondent for cnn's investigative
unit and of course our coverage will
begin tomorrow morning at seven o'clock
eastern time